I live in a place where a lot of people
[Music]
I live in a place where a lot of people
are constantly getting compared to and a
lot of people are very fit from where I
am
if you're not flat or if you're not fit
then you're not beautiful but I think
that's really wrong and one thing to be
always mindful of as you're beautiful in
your own skin and
[Music]
take control or tell you'll need
that I'm an a-hole and he brought a
knife to school and I reported him and
he got expelled who knows what he could
have done to me or other people with a
knife it's a better thing to know
nobody's gonna get hurt or yourself for
that person and then everybody's gonna
be safe I felt way better and no life
is just less crazy and it was before the
most painful thing I've been told is
about how bad my skin looks are like how
dark I am has a degrading way like I'm
less of a human like I'm not as good as
anybody else that is different for me
you came up with that answer really
quick for the asking
why do you think it stands out to you so
much because of the frequency and just
how deep those scars go fine hands to
talk to because keeping faint I'm
harboring those feelings to yourself is
really damaging it affects your
self-esteem overall and having like
nobody to talk to
just damages your entire mentality
Ericka thing I made what did you make a
paper necklace how did it make you feel
that probably and my mom saying she
hates me she always had told me my
entire life that I that every time I say
I hate somebody she's like oh you don't
actually hate them it's really hard to
hate somebody you have to gather up a
lot of hatred towards them and so the
fact that she was able to say that to me
after she had told me that my entire
life made me think that like am I really
that bad
just don't believe it and be happy
whether they like you or not
and they probably don't hate you so
because they're your parents and just to
keep loving them and tell them how that
felt and say
appreciate that and tell you sorry well
like someone told me that like my one of
my closest friends told me that they
weren't my friend ever again and they
hated me so what I did was like well I'm
sorry you feel that way and stuff like
that and one of the funniest things I've
done is that like give them compliments
if they're being weird to you that's my
advice that was the reason that my dad
left my biological dad left my life
I know I'm not the reason why but I did
hurt at the time a lot also this my my
one of my old friends my friend no more
there are just table people in the world
just got to get over it you know life's
tough things not been the matter what
people say you got to believe in
yourself and not put negative things not
put negative things like in your head
about yourself because that's been a
problem that I've dealt with in the past
it's always bothered me that my dad left
my life but I mean I he's the one who's
missing out on us I guess like
counselors kind of like snapping me into
reality that like my dream schools like
the big like Ivy League's aren't really
like in reach for me I guess when you're
younger like TV shows always like
teaching that your dreams are so easy to
get if you try you'll achieve your
dreams for like as you get older you
start to realize alike sometimes matter
how hard you try it like really
difficult to like still get there
honestly if those Dolson tell me that
I'd still be like in a fantasy world
kind of what makes you think that it's
not like like it's not going to happen
like what if it does I don't I'm just
like look up like stats and stuff and
then I just get so discouraged just to
given give us an idea of what kind of a
student you are do you mind sharing with
us what your GPA is at this moment I
have a 5-4 now
5.0 GPA yeah sometimes when I tell feel
with it I want to go to Olympics they
don't take me serious and they mostly
say like yeah whatever we don't really
care and stuff most of my age like type
of people believe in me but mostly
adults keep saying like like okay yeah
whatever you I just really loved figure
skating and I want to show the world
that I could be the best I just I don't
really care if I can't win a medal I
just like participating and challenging
myself
we don't cry unless you're injured why
did that for your feelings because even
know people hurt my feelings it's
hurting my feelings but if I'm not
injured that doesn't mean I can't cry
but my clothes never match
I thought about it and I said well well
what does it matter because you have
your own style your own personality and
your own thing and and I thought it was
like so I was kind of okay with it okay
do you have it but do you want to say
something to me people to make them stop
like what can you say to them how would
you feel if someone was mean to you that
I was in
we said it to my dad
how to make you feel like I cuss like I
was the worst like not feeling like
enough as a child is
really painful thing to go through
definitely lost paper blame
you still thought you died no he left
six years ago
you need to know that you are enough
like inside like you're just need to be
happy for yourself like in the ends like
all you have is yourself
and so like inner happiness it's like
your most important
about how my body was I've been short
and skinny and like
now I'm very insecure with my
don't listen to them
probably you
they haven't
and always liquors I was born in Germany
so this guy he used to call me a Nazi
and like that's not really fair so that
really hurt
was born somewhere
you can't like stereotype like that so
it's just not fair I left because of you
we said that my older sister how to make
you feel her because she's my sister and
she's the only one who I had to look up
to honestly just don't take it personal
just do what your heart desires and just
let the mean things go my mom calling me
disgusting I think was probably the
worst I think it was in a situation
where she felt powerless and felt like I
was like stronger and more powerful than
her and she does need something to cut
me down most of the time it's not them
actually believing what they're saying
it's a place of weakness and power and
powerlessness and themselves and that
it's not it's not always about you it's
more about what they're going through
inside of them usually that you're dumb
but
it's just a thing that people say cuz
they're jealous of you you know you're
trying they're not the more mistakes
that you're making is the harder that
you're trying it's proof that you're
that you're actually trying to do
something how did it make you feel the
first time didn't really matter but now
that they keep telling me and telling me
I just don't care no more they moved on
every decision that I make his made me
get up to this point I want to play
soccer on my friend but then he didn't
let me because the teams are even I want
said like can I at least be bull here
someday and then
No
[Music]
meanest thing I've been told it's
probably like being cursed out like now
I was like oh my gosh what did I just do
like why this is those four it's lucky I
didn't do anything so it's like if they
like tell you like nephew and like stuff
like that like I can hurt you a lot
it just hurts that the bump on my lip
that I have right here is very
disgusting and ugly it made me feel
really hurt and self-conscious about my
life my body but I want to appreciate it
for what it is if you're mean I'm really
sorry that you have to be mean to make
yourself look better I mean it is really
rude of you to say that but I hope you
find whatever is making you be ruinous
trainers are like why do you have a gap
of your teeth just don't be mean because
you're gonna make other people see me
and then you're just gonna make people
do
okay so the most hurtful thing I've been
told is if I had a gum disease and I was
like why like why would you think that
you know but how I got over it was
knowing died and have a gum disease and
then also like it hurt me and I kind of
like didn't want to show my teeth
anymore because I'm like if he thought
that then who else thinks that you know
but then I was like at the end of the
day it really doesn't matter what anyone
thinks cuz like I worry we are just
souls and bodies you know like our
bodies have nothing to do with who we
are it's just like figure I don't know
how to explain it but literally like
once I realized that Who I am matters
more than what my gums look like or what
anything looks like was how I got over
it if that makes sense
[Music]
hi everyone thanks for watching another
episode I hadn't made an outro in a
while so I thought I'd make a new one
today I hope you guys are okay with it
basically I just want to say welcome to
subscribers and to subscribers who have
been with me for awhile I want to thank
you for constantly supporting my channel
and to the new viewers who haven't
subscribed to my channel yet
so you get to the point where you want
to hit the subscribe button and possibly
the Bell next to it so you get another
bite every time I put up a new episode I
don't know if you guys have noticed but
a lot of my recent episodes have been
suggestions from you guys so I want to
thank you for that as well I have
noticed that you guys love suggesting
questions for my strangers answer series
which I love but I do want to let you
know that you could literally suggest
anything you want it doesn't just have
to be a question it could be like a
whole new project idea I'm always open
to trying new things as long as it lines
up with what my channel is about which
is doing things with strangers and
sharing good stories I think that's
pretty much it thank you guys again for
everything and I'll see you next week
[Music]